hi I'm Robin Seidel I'm the senior
special writer at The Wall Street
Journal and I've been covering Bitcoin
well I think there's a lot of risks for
a Bitcoin whether you're a user whether
you're a businessman whatever kind of
involvement you have there is first of
all price volatility the price of swings
have been enormous it was trading at you
know twenty dollars last year and now
it's about eight hundred dollars the
price swings are are pretty enormous and
you never know where it's gonna go
there's a lot of regulatory risk
governments around the world right now
are really looking at Bitcoin trying to
determine what they think about it
whether it can be used as a currency
whether it needs to be taxed so hard for
a user banks are scrutinizing Bitcoin
tremendously and so if you wire money to
an exchange in a place like Slovenia
that may get the bank's attention and it
might be kind of a nuisance for you to
answer questions from the bank banks are
obviously very worried about money
laundering
you